حراك سياسي قوي في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
المتوتره على كثير من الجبهات تقوده
السعوديه والدول الكبرى في المنطقه في
مسعا لاطفاء كثير من الحرائق التي ظلت
مشتعله لسنوات
عاد الضوء الى طاولات الحوار بدءا بتهدئه
التوتر بين عدد من دول المنطقه وتركيا
مرورا بلقاءات بين القيادات السياسيه
وانتهاء بالاتفاق مع انقره على ايجاد سبل
لحل الملفات او تهدئه حده الصراع في سوريا
وليبيا
العاشر من مارس شهد ايضا ولاده لاتفاق بين
السعوديه وايران برعايه صينيه بعد قطيعه
امتدت لنحو سبع سنوات اعطت املا بظهور
نتائج ايجابيه على ملفات عده بالمنطقه
كسوريا والعراق ولبنان واليمن الخطوه
الاخيره في سلسله التهدئه جاءت من اليمن
بعد زياره وفدي السعوديه وعمان لصنعاء
ولقائهما بقياده الحوثيين وبحث الوصول الى
الحل السياسي عبر عده مراحل يؤمل منها
اعاده الاستقرار الى اليمن بعد ثمان سنوات
من الحرب الدائره هناك
المسارات الدبلوماسيه التي انتهجتها دول
المنطقه صنعت تفاؤلا بمرحله جديده سمتها
الاستقرار وتغليب المصالح الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه على الصراع السياسي والعسكري
ولقيت اشاده دوليه واماميه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات